GHISLAIN PICARD, chef, Assem
Premières Nations QC et Labrador
- C'est une étape dans un...
qui est beaucoup plus étendu.
p p pape François a réitéré
sa demande de pardon envers
les peuples autochtones etonono.
Mais les demandes d'actionsconc.
- Je pense que c'est important
que... de finalement e e e e e ,
le pape François l'a fait hier
dans ses paroles, reconnaître
le concours de l'Église
catholique dans un vasrarararars
cultures et nos peuples,
ultimement.
- L'une des premières étapes
dans lautochtones, c'est l'accès
aux archives des communautés
religieuses.
MEDERIK SIOUI, consultant en
hisqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqsqs,
ils n'ont pas tant que ça
llllllaboré à l'accès à leurs
archives et encore moins
participé à trouver
- Une autre demande phare des
représentants autochtones au
pays est la révocation des
bulles papales qui ont défini
la doctrine de la découverte
ont accordé aux colonisateurs
le droit d'attaquer, de capturer
et de soumettre les peuples
autochtones qu'ils
rencontraient.
complètement, complètement
fausser l'histoire, complètement
fausser et dénigrer finalement
la présence de nos peuples.
- Autre geste symbolique
et d'objets autochtones
- Ça, c'est évidemmentfausser lt
fausser et dénigrer finalement
la présence de nos peuples.
- Autre geste symbolique
et d'objets autochtones
détenus pa V V Vatican et
les communautés religieuses.
ROXANE LÉVESQUE, assistante en
- Quand c'est les communautés
autonenenes elles-mêmes qui
possèdent les artéfacts qui
proviennent de leurs propresopos
ancêtres, bien, à ce moment-là,r
propre narratif pour présenter
leur propre histoire au public r
patrimoine par les Premières
de rebâtir des savoirs qui ont
été perd
- Pour ces gens-là, ça peut être
un objet qui est encore vivant
puis qui a une importance très
grande pour leur communauté.
de dire si l'Église accédera
un jour à ces demandes. Mai
le processus de réappropriation,
lui, est bien entamé.
que l'Église, elle-même, puisse
respecter justement cette
et culturelle et spirituelle
de lemememble nos peuples.
- Ici Flavie Sauvageau